wir haben im letzten Jahr einmal das
teuerste Essen beim Lieferservice
bestellt ihr habt das gefeiert ich auch
deshalb machen wir das ganze heute noch
mal ich freue mich sehr darauf ich würde
sagen wir fangen ohne lang zu reden
direkt an ich habe hier mein Handy ihr
seht an der Seite die Restaurants und
gehen einmal durch bisschen nach oben
bisschen runter ich will ja nicht wissen
was ich bekomme das erste Restaurant ist
Marie Restaurant afghanisch gar nicht
iranische Küche vorzügliches persisches
Essen habe ich wirklich Bock drauf
schöne Tags und Safranreis mit so einer
knackigen Kruste gucken wir mal was wir
bekommen also bei dem Suppen müssen
wahrscheinlich nicht lang gucken 7,6 €.
oh 16,50 € gekochte Lammhaxe in eigener
Soße mit Basmati Dill Reis und dicken
Bohnen sieht nicht so krass aus aber ist
schon relativ teuer 14 50 16 50 gibt's
mehrere 18 50
Safranreis bitte bitte gibt's nichts
teure
Grillplatte für zwei Personen 42 Euro 42
Euro ich glaube da gibt es nicht mehr
mein dann kommen wir beide auf unsere
Kosten und der Rest vom Büro auch also
hier kommt auf jeden Fall nichts weg wir
sind wieder mit sieben Mann im Büro
dritten teurer Tag heute für mich erste
bestellung ist raus ich muss sagen ich
bin nicht wirklich unzufrieden also ist
schon nicht schlecht ich hätte
vielleicht lieber so eine Tarik sowas
knuspriges gehabt aber ganz verkehrt ist
es glaube ich nicht gucken wir weiter
nach dem nächsten Restaurant zack zack
zack das nächste Restaurant trägt den
Namen
Medina kennen wir doch sogar Medina
werberische Küche ja da hatte ich mal
diese kranke Sache bestellt das waren
diese Tajine boah das war richtig lecker
aber das war so sicher nicht das
teuerste
17,16 € 15 €
18,50 € gemischter Gerät Teller ich sehe
mehr Geld Pommes Salat Dips ja und wir
können uns Aussehen ob wir Pommes oder
Couscous wollen ich finde das geil weil
das Restaurant war richtig gut also der
gemischte Dritter sieht wirklich nicht
so ansprechend aus aber das war wirklich
so next level ich würde auf jeden Fall
Couscous nehmen weil wir haben so viel
Staffel ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen Cleaner Grillteller ich
bestelle jetzt und dann gucken wir mal
ob wir beim nächsten Mal vielleicht
etwas kriegen dass kein Geld heller ist
und wir suchen das letzte Restaurant ich
hoffe wirklich keine Platte vor allem
nicht so eine XXXL Grillplatte für 200 €
oder so
McDonald's wir machen noch mal neu
eat for fit Soulfood in gesunder
Variante
bitte nicht wenn ich das jetzt bestellt
dann bin ich wirklich der größte
idiotonno Salat 20 Euro 60 ich kenne das
Restaurant ich war doch mal mit Paul
unterleitner erzählen Köln war die haben
halt essen was eigentlich keine Ahnung
Burger Pizza nicht so gesund ist in
super gesunder und vor allem
fitnessbewusster Ausführung eric hat die
die Neujahrsvorsätze sehr ernst genommen
und ich glaube der freut sich auf jeden
Fall wenn wir hier bestellen Porno Salat
für 20 €, Steak passt da 15 € warum
kostet der Thunfischsalat über 20 das
müssen wir herausfinden gegrilltes
Rumpsteak ja 280g mit Erdnussbutter und
Mango Chilisoße
33,90 [ __ ] da müssen wir nicht mehr
weiter reden dann bestellen wir uns ein
Rumpsteak ich weiß nicht ob ich in
meinem Leben schon jemals rumsteckt
bestellt habe ich werde jetzt tun wir
haben wirklich eine wilde Auswahl heute
getroffen also Glück gehabt mit den
Restaurants alles kommt vom Grill heute
eigentlich das so ein bisschen das Grill
special ich bestelle und dann würde ich
sagen warten wir mal bis das erste
Gericht ankommt und die erste Erstellung
von persischen Restaurants da ich sag
Euch so viel das ist wirklich eine Menge
essen also es ist richtig schwer sollte
es aber auch sein ich meine 42 Euro sind
schon eine Menge dafür müssen wir auch
ordentlich was bekommen wir gucken mal
wie viel wir bekommen so und WoW okay
schöne Präsentation für so einen
bestelltes Essen muss ich sagen da kommt
direkt so die Assoziation dass sie das
irgendwie dabei sich schön auf dem Grill
hatten und relativ frisch hier
reingepackt haben gefällt mir auch der
Grill flavorit ist direkt in der Luft ne
und da ist aber auch wirklich reichlich
Zeug dabei also ich glaube wenn man das
zu zweit bestellt ist man auf jeden Fall
pappsatt wow doppelte Portion Reis das
ist nicht schlecht das hätte ich auch
nicht gedacht 1,2 das ist ja wirklich
mit dem Fleisch und sowas das sind ja
wirklich Portionen oder das ist nicht
für zwei Personen das ist für eine
family eigentlich oder
vier Leute essen ich habe sie Mittag was
soll ich sagen ich mache als allererstes
einmal oh die ist so schön geschmolzen
hier die Butter über den Reis denkst du
siehst du siehst ja ja
[Musik]
also wirklich probieren wo ich die
Butter reingeträuft habe aber ich merke
schon so eine richtig geile fluffige
Konsistenz
wie gut es bitte einfach Reis mit Butter
ja die machen Reis anders dicker so Eric
für dich auch
erstmal
hier so ein gelb hier vom Butter reicht
luftig
ist das perfekte Wort und den Reis zu
beschreiben probieren wir mal ob das
Fleisch auch feinig schmeckt wir testen
bitte als erstes aber auch direkt so
weißt du was mir direkt auffällt 42 €
kriegen wir nicht mal irgend Soße ich
weiß was du meinst so eine Joghurtsoße
fertig
super gut richtig schön weich sehr sehr
extrem saftig
alleine das schwimmt auch so in Butter
noch mal und so checken
[Musik]
chicken auch gut aber für mich keine
Erleuchtung wirklich sehr gelungen 42
Euro ist viel Geld persisches Essen ist
aber meine Erfahrung nach sowieso immer
ein bisschen teurer aber es hat mir so
ein bisschen gefehlt ich so ein Joghurt
Dip oder so ein zwei Sachen haben
gefehlt aber das teuerste ist halt auch
nicht immer das allerbeste Stopp ihr
habt es gemerkt das teuerste ist nicht
immer das Beste aber bei wifood weiß ich
immer woran ich bin
dürft ihr in letzter Zeit kaum ein recht
vorbeigegangen sein ich meine sie
unterstützen tolle Projekte wie seven vs
wild und wofür ich sehr dankbar bin
jetzt auch nicht wifood ist eine
Trinkmahlzeit die euch drei bis fünf
Stunden sättigt sie enthält 26 Vitamine
wichtige Mineralstoffe und ist natürlich
vollkommen Gluten und laktosefrei und
wenn ihr wollt sogar vegan wenn wir im
Team stressige gedreht haben ist waipood
immer dabei beispielsweise wir fahren zu
einem drehen ein bisschen weiter
entfernt ist haben keine Zeit für ein
Frühstück dann ist unser Frühstück wir
kommen gut gelaunt und gesättigt beim
Dreh an und können Vollgas für euch
geben außerdem ist die Verpackung zu
100% Klima neutral und die Flasche ist
Recycling war es gibt aber nicht nur die
Trinkmahlzeiten sondern auch Riegel hot
Bolls und Pulver für euren Shaker es ist
auch für jeden Geschmack was dabei von
Smoot Vanilla classic heavy hazard und
Schoko crazy Coconut über Kaffee bis hin
zu happy banana ihr wisst ja ich leg
mich nicht so gern fest was mein
Lieblingsgericht oder irgendwas ist aber
mein aktueller Favorit ist auf jeden
Fall fresh Berry und das beste ist als
ihr euch ausprobieren wollt was
vielleicht euer persönlicher Favorit
wird könnt ihr das tun mit dem Code max
mit denen ihr zehn Prozent auf das
gesamte Sortiment spart so auch auf die
Probierpakete deshalb vielen lieben Dank
an wipood für die Unterstützung meines
Kanals und dieses Videos weiter geht's
mit der nächsten Bestellung die Jungs
machen sich gerade hinten noch einen
Teller fertig die zweite Bestellung ist
in der Zwischenzeit angekommen die
zweite Grillplatte bis heute die Tages
wir haben hier oben Baguette oh ich
erinnere mich ja das war so ein Ding bei
dem Restaurant die haben zu allem
Baguette gereicht und ich dachte mir so
hä das haben die Leute in den
Kommentaren haben mich dann erst
aufgeklärt ja ein berberisches
Restaurant das ist in Nordafrika die
Region quasi und die war französisches
Einflussgebiet deshalb gibt's da viel
Baguette auch bei ihm das hier ist
unsere Grillplatte 18,50 € hat der Spaß
gekostet das macht das Ganze zu
teuersten Bestellung das macht das Ganze
zum teuersten Gericht das macht das
Ganze zum teuersten Gericht dass das
Restaurant zu bieten hat und das beste
ist ich habe ja schon ein sehr leckeres
gegessen
woW ist schon mit Liebe gemacht oder so
eine schöne Variation sehr bunt checken
wir erstmal gemeinsam was überhaupt
dabei ist wir haben hier verschiedene
undefinierbare Dinge ich finde das sieht
so aus wie so ein Gemüse Patty ja aber
so Gemüse aber ich glaube es trotzdem
mit Fleisch also das ist auch geil
gegrillte Zwiebeln
die bringen so eine Saftigkeit auch mit
sich und gegrillte Zwiebeln sind so die
verraten dass das Restaurant sich Mühe
gibt weil die Geräte Zwiebeln brauchen
Zeit so das ist nichts für jemanden der
einfach alles hat Kichererbsen zack zack
zack ich habe das Gefühl dass das
wirklich schon so eine nice vollwertige
Mahlzeit ist gut aus gerade mit dem
Couscous statt den Pommes
geschmackvoller also ich mache den Reis
gerade aber der hat viel mehr Gewürz
dran der Couscous so der hat so eine
orientalische Note irgendwie unfassbar
viel Gewürze drin werden jetzt seine
gemüsefrikadelle muss man die
karmelisierten Zwiebeln probieren
auch geil wirklich an allem sind so
untypische Gewürze so für den deutschen
Raum das Hähnchenfleisch ist Berlet
könnte saftiger sein vielleicht
die andere passt ich glaube das ist
Paprika für mich
ganz ehrlich dafür gebe ich gerne mehr
Geld aus wenn ich sowas geiles neues
exotisches einfach zu mir nach Hause
geliefert bekomme und so eine nice
Erfahrung schmeckt mir jetzt auch ne
also mir schmecken ja viele Dinge aber
das schmeckt mir besonders gut das ist
so nice experience dafür gebe ich gerne
Geld aus und die letzte Bestellung zum
Glück habe ich die Jungs die mir beim
Essen helfen weil sonst wäre es langsam
knapp wir haben wirklich viele Essen
bekommen das hier ist die letzte
Bestellung das ist unser Rumpsteak für
33,90 € und das
sind die Pommes dazu kommen den Salat
wollen wir auch mal probieren
festliche Pommes rein die Tapes ich
würde sagen das erste Mal wo ich sage 33
90 okay schon echt teuer gerade weil das
Steak nicht viel versprechend aussieht
aber wir haben eine Stange Rosmarin
dabei ja komm machen wir 50 Euro nein
also Pommes
da ist nicht mal an den echten Crunch ne
ja ist jetzt nicht so hammergeil ne bist
ja auch ein Restaurant für eine ganz
bestimmte Zielgruppe bei sehr
fitnessbewussten sehr
ernährungsbewussten Menschen und genau
weiß was du das zu dir nimmst als einige
wenige überhaupt auch so Konzepte
entwickelt haben wie diese Pommes und so
ist ja schon echt gut was für ein Stück
Fleisch soll das sein sieht für mich aus
wie ein Filet dann
Rumpsteak also ich muss wirklich sagen
das sieht jetzt sieht ein bisschen
traurig aus ist auch nicht so viel
Kameramann klassischen ja also es ist
sorry das Ding ist wir müssen glaube ich
beide schon ein Stück weit gedacht nee
Steak zu liefern es halt echt gefährlich
so sollte genau das hat auch mit am
längsten gedauert das kommt aus der
Südstadt also mit dem Auto oder sagen
wir mal mit dem Roller wahrscheinlich
mit dem Roller am schnellsten sind es
trotzdem so zehn zwölf Minuten hier
rüber dann wartet der Lieferant
irgendwie ein bisschen verfärbt sich
oder sowas wie willst du dann noch
sicherstellen dass der Garpunkt gut ist
und wir wurden ja nicht mal gefragt sein
soll ne also
einfach eine eine Order und ich meine
das ist ultra well dann also du kommst
kaum rein mit der Gabel bin ich dumm
weil ich bestellt habe weil ich
eigentlich besser wusste dass ein Steak
halt in der Regel nicht irgendwie super
perfekt gegart ankommt wenn man es
bestellt hat oder es ist einfach falsch
das im Angebot zu haben gerade wenn es
so teuer ist wie gesagt gar kein Held
gegen den Laden ich war schon dort ich
finde das Konzept richtig geil ich finde
auch das Essen vor Ort für das was es
ist richtig gut das sollte nicht sein
also darf man nicht liefern also es
schmeckt nicht schlecht ne aber man kann
zwei Stunden trotzdem wieder meine coole
Erfahrung während Sachen gegessen die
wir sonst nicht gegessen hätten wir
haben Erfahrungen gemacht wir wissen
vielleicht was wir nicht wieder
bestellen werden und es hat vor allem
extrem viel Geld gekostet deshalb lasst
gerne ein Like da abonniert den Kanal
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder ich verabschiede mich jetzt in
den Skiurlaub und kommen dann wohl
erholt wieder für euch zurück mit einem
coolen Video bis dahin macht's gut und
ciao